bueno pues en esta ocasión tenemos la
integral indefinida de x 3 todo esto que
multiplica a x menos 1 elevado a la
quinta potencia de x y tal vez pienses
si elevamos x menos 1 a la quinta
potencia podemos utilizar la fórmula del
binomio de newton y así resolver este
tipo de binomio elevado a la quinta
potencia sin embargo va a ser muy muy
largo y muy tardado y después de eso lo
tendremos que multiplicar por x 3 y
bueno podría ser una forma de resolverlo
pero qué tal si sale por sustitución
entonces la idea de este vídeo es hacer
este tipo de problema por sustitución y
tal vez no parezca tan sencillo sin
embargo elevar x menos 1 la quinta
potencia va a ser mucho más tardado que
la forma en lo que yo lo voy a resolver
entonces como el binomio x menos 1 es el
que está elevado a la quinta potencia es
muy buen candidato para un es igual a x
menos 1 y entonces la derivada de v es
igual a
x bueno recuerden que esto pasa si sólo
si la derivada de eeuu con respecto a x
es igual a 1 aquí tenemos la derivada de
x que es 1 la derivada de menos 1 se va
y esto pasa si y sólo si y bueno ya
tenemos esto entonces podemos tratar de
reescribir esta integral me queda la
integral vamos a ponerlo aquí de quien y
yo tengo primero x + 3 esto no está en
términos de 1 sin embargo podemos
intentar pensarlo como en términos de v
y aquí es como hacer la sustitución
hacia atrás porque fíjense yo tengo que
hubo es igual a x + 1 esta es una
igualdad por lo tanto yo puedo sumar uno
de los dos lados de la ecuación y me va
a quedar que más uno es igual a x uno
más uno es igual a equis y ya con esto
estamos despejando a x de aquí youtube
el valor de x en términos de eeuu y
puedo sustituirla en el primer factor y
que me queda pues x 3 es lo mismo x es
lo mismo que uno más uno entonces me
queda uno más uno ya esto hay que
sumarle tres entonces dejen de
escribirlo x
11 y a esto le sumamos 3 y todo esto lo
vamos a multiplicar por x menos 1 pero x
menos 1 es y por lo tanto tengo elevado
a la quinta potencia y elevado a la
quinta potencia diferencial de x por el
diferencial de x es lo mismo que el
diferencial de eeuu y me queda de eeuu y
bueno está integral la podemos escribir
de una manera mucho más sencilla usando
álgebra el álgebra elemental por lo
tanto tenemos que más 13 es lo mismo que
uno más cuatro esto de aquí es uno más
cuatro que multiplica a su vez a quinta
entonces me queda aún más cuatro que
multiplica su vez a un elevado a la
quinta potencia diferencial de iu y
bueno ahora si yo multiplico cuatro por
quinta me va a quedar un integral muy
sencilla las integrales que empezamos a
ver desde un principio y todo esto lo
estoy logrando con un cambio de variable
muy sencillo por lo tanto vamos seguir
esta integral me queda un +4 que
multiplica a un quinta me queda un
quinta por su quinta por cuatro y esto
va a ser igual a la integral de
sexta más cuatro veces y quinta y todo
esto todo esto diferencial de un y
resolver esta integral es muy fácil
porque es la integral de una potencia de
una potencia que depende de eeuu y date
cuenta que el haber elevado este binomio
a la quinta potencia y va a ser muy
pesado por lo tanto el hacer el cambio
de variable de v es bastante positivo
para resolver este tipo de integrales y
si empiezas a pensar un poco en futuro
al final te vas a dar cuenta que todo
nos va a quedar escrito en términos de x
menos 1 a la quinta potencia entonces
vamos a resolver esta integral me queda
que a la sexta integral diferencial de 1
es lo mismo que elevado a la 7 entre 7
le sumamos el exponente entonces me
queda igual a 7 entre 7 más la integral
de 4 veces su quinta diferencial de 1 es
igual le sumamos un exponente me queda
cuatro veces elevado a la sexta entre 6
y ya todo esto hay que sumarle la
constante de integración y bueno esto se
puede reducir un poco 4 sextos es lo
mismo que dos tercios entonces me queda
o elevado las 7 entre 100
más dos tercios de elevado a la sexta
más una constante de integración y ahora
sí si recordamos que vale igual a x
menos 1 podemos sustituir y todo va a
quedar en términos de x me queda x menos
1 elevado a la séptima potencia entre 7
más dos tercios de x menos uno elevado a
la sexta potencia más una constante de
integración y fíjate qué bonito
resultado nos quedó porque todo depende
de x menos 1 en lugar de quedarnos un
polinomio enorme nos queda todo
expresado en términos del binomio que
tenía la potencia y en lugar de
complicarnos la vida resolvimos este
problema haciendo una sustitución y una
sustitución hacia atrás y obteniendo un
resultado que se ve bastante elegante